the ex-flights of american scouts and
soldiers on the plains have an endless
fascination to every american young and
old tonight i have the very special
honor of introducing a fighting man of
the old indian wars and of the civil war
as well
corporal leander herrera retired company
a third u.s infancy now living at saint
paul nebraska
corporal heron now in his 85th year
is one of the few men still alive who
helped in the defense of the old santa
fe trail
he fought worked and played with wild
bill hitchcock and deadwood dick
and is the only man in the state of
nebraska who holds the congressional
medal of honor and so it gives me great
pleasure to introduce corporal harrell
who will tell you about that bit of
indian history which won him his coveted
decorations
corporal o'hara
[Music]
thank you captain rickenbacker
back in the 60s fort dodge kansas
was a distributing point for surprise
along the santa fe trail
we were fighting with the indians all
the time
and my hardest scrap of them
took place near fort dodge in september
1868.
that was 62 years ago
but i remembered as clearly as if it had
happened but yesterday
one evening the commanding officer at
fort dodge
ordered me to choose the conference
and carried his father's support
learners
75 miles away
i was a young fellow then
and i felt honored by the assignment
because such well-known scouts says wild
bill hickok
california joe
and apacheville
were at the court and might have been
chosen
we could see the indians signaling
with smoke and fire on the hilltops in
all directions
and batman's troubles
so i picked patty boyle who tried and
true friends and a brave man to come
along with me
that sounds like a tough assignment
corporal
it was captain
but that night we managed to sneak out
of the fort
and were well on our way went up near
little [ __ ] creek we heard
rifles fire
and the blood thirdly yelled at the envy
we swung away
from the trail
and there holding in a routine
were four men had a new team
the cracks and clash of rifles around
the edge of the ravine
showed that the indians have been in a
process
we were on an important mission
our daughters were to perceive the
portlanders
with all possible speeds
but i just couldn't see those white men
massively so we spurred our horses and
cut through the circle of indians and
joined the little group in the ravine
i sent boyle who had the best horse
back to the fort for help
the brave fellow plunged down the ravine
which opened out on the plains and
although it was night the indians
somehow
saw him and went swooping after him
we had stood we assumed he had been
killed
and we decided to sell our lives
at the highest possible thought
the indians kept rushing
us on their horses
hanging on the far side of the
mount
so that we had only a leg and an arm
to shoot us
soon they began to suffer casualties
one of our men was tomahawk in a hand a
hand come back with a husky bridge
bullets and airs disabled the others
so that two of us had to bear the brunt
of the defense
then our ammunition began to run low
the indians were making
smaller third and smaller
circles around us
and it looked
like the end had arrived
then just as they seemed to be preparing
for the final rush
a body of horsemen in white appeared
at first
we thought they were indians in disguise
but they
called out in english and when the
leader galloped up it was boiled
at the head of his pardon from the
seventh united states cavalry why the
white uniforms corporal o'hara it wasn't
uniform captain
the garrison
of the fort had been asleep when boiled
away
and they jumped from their book box
and rushed to our rescue in their night
shirts and underwear
strange to say
i came through without a stretch
i didn't count the number of times the
wagon was struck but those who did told
me
that it was hit 500 times of bullets and
arrows
and those arrows were sticking out like
quills on important lines
a truly wonderful story corporal and
certainly one that fulfills the medal of
honor provision as being above and
beyond the call of duty but a man who
fought the indians on the plains and
also saw action in the civil war must
have some wonderful memories
you went through the biggest war of all
captain rickenbacker
and you won't know
how true your words are until you get to
be as old as i am
once back in 66
i came back to fort dodge with a party
of nine soldiers
who had been sent to rescue two girls
who were held captive by the indians
their names bucks
their father had been killed
and the mother and other sisters were
also missing
they were held in an indian village way
back in the wichita mountains
a regiment
a region where
[Music]
no white man had ever been seen foot
after days of traveling we found them
was there any actual fighting involved
corporal
no
we got them back in return for two wagon
modes of completions and trinkets
well on our return journey
we were expecting an ambush every day
and frankly i never expected to get back
alive
but finally we did get back
and the box girls were given the
childrens of care first
by army surgeons and later by mrs
general custer who had come to the fort
with her famous husband
and
and through all these years
i have never forgotten the gentleness
and kindness of that brave little woman
who chose to be at her husband's side
whenever she possibly could what became
of the box family afterwards corporal
did the mother and other sister escape
yes
they were eventually brought safely
into the fort
and i have been wandering
for 64 years just what did become this
and tomorrow i may know the answer
for tomorrow i'm going to see if i can't
find
a dear friend of the old pioneer days
a brave woman
whose famous husband
made his last stand in the master creed
of the little big horn
i deferred and this is general custer
who i understand is still living
right here in new york
and now captain rickenbacker
you've been asking me a lot of questions
how about you
you have the conventional medal of honor
and a lot of other decorations what's
your story
well corporal our time is almost up so i
won't be able to answer that question
tonight but i do want to thank you for
this page you have given us out of the
most dramatic period in our country's
development
it is very much worthwhile for americans
of this generation to pause and consider
the hardships of the soldiers the
pioneer and the indian scouts like
yourself who within a single lifetime
have doubled the size of our country
through winning of the west